[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
john berry was on the call last night
game three between the nets and bucks on
espn he has jazz clippers
saturday night also on espn radio the
former
nba veteran joining us on the program
john good to have you back thanks for
joining us
let's start at the end of that game we
had all this conversation about who's
going to take the last shot for the nets
in a million years if i would have said
you know bruce brown is going to take
that last shot for the nets what would
you have said
um no thanks uh like
it was a discombobulated possession
obviously they threw it in bounds the
ball rolls all the way across the court
uh you know bruce had some time to wait
for kyrie wait for kevin durant to give
him that basketball
uh look bruce brown played great and
this guy's a 6-4
center uh he was a point guard i believe
in miami university of miami and he's
come out and
he plays the center position it's
incredible uh
but yeah obviously uh the possession
didn't go like they wanted
uh tough shot over the top of brook
lopez but i'm just shocked at that game
86-83 is a bad three-quarters normally
for brooklyn
and they get 83 points for the game uh
it was
stunning that these two offenses were
that bad last night but
this is by design for milwaukee it was a
physical game tough game
do they have to keep that score under
110 under 100 if they have any chance of
winning this series
they would like to um you know but
typically you're going to have to score
to beat brooklyn
that's the bottom line uh even without
james harden where they get 125 and 115
in the first two games
uh that was shocking i mean you what
were they they they
scored 11 points in the first quarter
you know down 19
after one kevin durant doesn't go 11 for
28 very often
and that won't happen again so i if i'm
milwaukee do i take
confidence out of that that i held
brooklyn to 83 and i won
i don't think so i still think brooklyn
has been by far the better team
throughout these first three games
yeah and then you have the the giannis
situation he's he's not a good shooter
you can't put him on the line
um what you were a great free throw
shooter your father one of the great
free throw shooters in nba history
what is it that happens at the line with
some of these players that they almost
look paralyzed john
uh do do some people not like to be
the center of attention like i i'm not
saying you're scared but you're standing
there and you know
whatever's in the building 20 000 or
whatever or watching you
uh i mean look i played with shaq we
would shoot free throws every day
when i was with the lakers in 97. he
would go
18 for 20 17 for 20 all the time
and i don't know does fatigue play into
it
i'm not exactly sure but i would say
this is
get the routine faster he he got called
for one last night the 10-second rule he
had 13 seconds they gave him
um i would go quicker colin montgomery a
great golfer right
great ryder cupper and he always he
always said the longer you stand over a
ball
the more bad things are going to get in
your head so
know what you have to do he knows what
he's got to do get the ball get a
routine that's quick
shoot it shoot it with confidence and
move on well we see this with ben
simmons
i don't think ben has bad form but
he doesn't bend at his knees and then
like there's no fluidity to it
it's these guys get there and they're
like stiff and then
there's no movement from the ground up
uh
his form is not great uh the elbow's out
a bit
uh i'd rather have your form to be quite
honest watching you and maybe some of
the dinettes back there
um yeah
didn't somebody shoot a jump shot from
the free throw line that really
struggled
years ago do you remember wilt
chamberlain did
did he he took jumpers well no he he was
at the top of the key he was so bad
um how grier played for the 76ers how
greer took a jump shot from the free
throw line okay
yeah i i know i think my dad talked
wilton to trying underhand for a minute
uh but guys are a bit embarrassed about
it but it it's amazing i mean you bring
up ben simmons and
like how can guys be this great at
basketball
and you cannot make a 10-foot jump shot
or you're not even willing to take it i
know but look ben simmons is great
this guy's a great player but i mean
isn't that like don't you start as a kid
i i think he one day i'm gonna make a
free throw he could be a great player i
don't think he's a great player
well i think he he can control ball
games
and be the best player on the floor at
times and
but that time can't be at the end of a
game when i know that he
is going to have to shoot a free throw
and he like he can't shoot a free throw
or a three-pointer
it's like the greek freak he can't shoot
he can control a game
and i wonder is is is giannis a one
or or is he more of a two who can rely
on or needs to rely on one
um that's that's a good question
obviously in the playoffs he
hasn't proven to be a one that's taken
his team to where they need to be
yeah and look he's he's four for 32
from the three-point line now in the
playoffs and
last night i'm i mean i'm not i have no
affiliation with the bucks
even though i played there i try to
forget my time there
he he i was like i'm frustrated watching
this like
don't shoot a three i don't care if
you're giannis or if you're michael
jordan
i'd be like don't shoot him anymore i
mean
it serves no purpose four for 32.
i mean that's just you can't do it we're
talking to john berry the uh former nba
veteran who apparently played on just
about every team in the nba
so just eight all that was it that's
seven
maybe seven so yeah the worst stop was
milwaukee
well it was cold
and we and we stunk okay all right other
than that it was the great they're great
people in milwaukee and great broads
uh paulie do you have how many games yes
i got
john berry with eight teams and uh 36
starts out of 821 games
hey man try coming off the bench for
some of these starters and they whine
about whatever
it's hard to do it's a skill
he uh he was on the call last night game
three between the nets and bucks he's
got the
jazz and the clippers game three i'm
trying to figure out the clippers here
john
i got two really good wing defenders who
can't guard anybody on the wings
so help me out here john yeah
well and throw in pat beverly he's
supposed to be a
a superior wing defender yeah and you
had luca
torch him for 36 a night in a six in a
seven game series
and now donovan mitchell gets what 82
points in two games
um yeah and there were two winnable
games i mean the clippers give them
credit
you know they come back from 21 down in
the third quarter last night
and have an opportunity uh kawhi
hasn't really gone off like he did a
couple times in the dallas
in the dallas series um you know ty lue
he he switches it up on a game to game
basis doesn't he i mean no rondo last
night
sometimes he plays zoobots sometimes he
plays small sometimes he plays big uh
he's searching
and um i'm not sure what to think i i
i'd feel a lot better if i was the
clippers and i were the bucks
even though they're down two nothing as
they go home who do you think is more
likely to play for a championship
first devin booker donovan mitchell
those two teams are both scary um
you know obviously i don't think denver
has an opportunity to get out with the
loss of jamal murray
but uh i i think if we see phoenix utah
in the next series
that is a complete toss-up in my opinion
and
monty williams you can't say enough they
won 19 games two years ago
yeah and they they're they're terrific
they played with great confidence devin
booker is
phenomenal and chris paul obviously can
you believe chris paul's never gotten
out
of the second round in his career how is
that possible well that's why when
people say
you got to have chris paul and he's a
great leader and he's a winner
but he hadn't won really he's never
gotten out of the second round
i know i mean and he he single-handedly
had a couple of times
where he was directly responsible for
them not getting out
you remember he tried a three-quarter
court shot against oklahoma city because
he thought he was drawing a foul to get
three free throws
and they didn't call it and they lost
the game
and then they were he's with the
clippers they were up
20 on houston in the second half to
close out a series
lost and lost in seven i mean some
unbelievable inexplicable losses for
chris paul but
i i don't doubt his greatness because
he's great and he is a great leader
what's going to happen with the lakers
in the offseason aside from lebron
changing his jersey number
complete overhaul overhead
oh i don't think schroeder's back i
think they try to move kuzma
uh wesley matthews gone uh
they'll try to probably resign caruso uh
i don't think drummond goes back gasal
will be gone
you know i mean i i think it's a total
overhaul wow
yeah why why not they're they're
three-point shooting i mean look they
they were hurt and when we went into
this went into the playoff
game playing games excuse me i mean they
literally could have lost that game to
the golden
state warriors at home they had not
played together they had drummond
who just got there they didn't play with
lebron and a.d
schroeder was out for two weeks protocol
they were totally discombobulated and
you could see their offense was
completely out of sorts and they were
they were banged up
so i'll give them that excuse and you
know but think about this too dan
they won a bubble championship last year
look at all the players that they've
given up to get anthony davis now let's
say they don't win another championship
with lebron
and they gotta what a two or three year
window of that if they never win again
is that worth it
probably yeah okay yeah i mean i think
you got to get one it's like if the nets
get one this was worth it
right well the nets tried it a few years
ago with kevin garnett and paul pierce
and that didn't pan out so well but i
mean look at the talent that the lakers
have given up on right julius randle
brandon ingram
josh hart lamello ball i mean uh lonzo
ball
uh who else i mean jordan clarkson
there are a lot of guys that they
mortgaged you know to get this
done and they got their one title so
maybe they'll be happy but what's the
what's the reputation with anthony davis
uh i think great player um
just fragile i guess i mean or you know
or you can say unlucky
okay um and is he really a truly a
number one
guy i know he's not playing as the
number one guy now but
when lebron leaves is he enough to be
your number one guy in kerry you do
championship didn't work in new orleans
obviously didn't have the talent but
now can he be a number one but is that
more mindset though john
that you have to want to be the guy
that you know the that mentality of like
iverson
every night like i'm gonna be the guy
you know
all of these guys that you played
against or with you had to have that
mentality of
when i go out there i'm the man i don't
know if anthony davis
feels that way will feel that way when
lebron's not there
you know does the grey freak think he's
the one when he goes out there
should he think he's the one i just
wonder about that whole mindset of
i want it man i want i want the game on
the line
the ball in my hands well how many guys
you think have been like that
in the history of the league no really
not a lot
not as many as people think correct
because you guys know
you knew that there are guys who had
alligator arms you know when they're
game on the line
you want to throw it to them and then
they may not want it
give me those names give me those names
for those guys
[Laughter]
because you have to want it and i just
wonder if
like playoff p you want to be paid
like you're a star but you got to act
like a star
yeah and well you have to perform like
it and like and it's
it's i mean you start with michael
jordan right i mean
that that guy there's no question that
that would be the guy
right he wants kobe kobe's there
yeah yeah is lebron that guy
well you played against all three so you
play against jordan kobe and lebron
yeah game on the line what was the
biggest difference
uh well i i well
lebron would be more apt to make the
pass
okay right is it the correct play
probably
but michael jordan do you think he cared
about the correct play
he did give it to steve kerr right when
john stockton came over and doubled you
know
steve kerr hit the shot but michael was
reluctant to do that for many
years and until he he didn't win until
he started trusting his teammates right
yeah
uh but uh michael jordan
and kobe bryant is as close to michael
jordan as anybody i think we've ever
seen so those two guys but lebron is
great at
like i don't know if there's a better
guy getting to the hoop
in nba history but does he go there at
the end of the does he go there at the
end of games
no
how would you not want to god the game
on the line
like he he's under 70 percent from the
line i just
that how about giannis was 53
coming in john you could shoot
blindfolded
and i know this is true i would make
five out of ten
you would make you would make more than
that
i would hope yeah if i yeah
you would too yeah i know i would but
i'm
obviously a great shooter john yes well
it's all relative okay ben simmons
giannis and me
in a shooting contest oh yeah i'll take
him 100
100 and that's the right answer there
that's the right answer
well yes yeah of course it is on the
golf course
no no i'm better than ben simmons and
giannis on the golf i'm talking i'm
talking about me and you oh no no
no no you're really good on there but
see i i have a full-time job
i'm not full-time no no you're not
full-time
i mean come on you mail it in like you
give me
you give me a couple of couple of hours
and that's it you can play golf all day
i try to i know you do if my
if my wine drinking doesn't get in the
way
but okay you got game three uh coming up
over the weekend
uh so yeah you got a couple of days off
john
i do um today will be a tough day are
you gonna be
studying tape is that what you're gonna
try to tell us oh i'll re-watch
both games last night yes oh okay and
then we'll
we'll get going yeah do you have a
grudge do you hold a grudge against
anybody you played
with like all these years later are you
still sort of
frosty at somebody uh just every coach
that didn't play anymore
i mean that's all
yeah jeff van gundy he didn't play me
enough no no no
i i just you know the game is hard the
game is not as fun to watch for me as it
was
back when i played in the 90s it you
know
you you remember you you steve did it
it's just that
everybody kind of does the same thing
you know it's it's high pick and roll
get a switch
circle somebody out that you want to get
one on one everybody get the hell out of
the way
and drive the ball if they help kick it
to a three-point shooter
and then we move on but you look at
these rules and i just wonder what
certain players from another era
would have been like with today's rules
if i would allowed
like what kind of player would magic be
in today's game
uh yeah like would would michael be
shooting threes
um yeah kobe would be
kobe i mean even greater um
because he could how would you guard
kobe and michael jordan
i would you can't i could you can't yeah
you can't touch them
i mean i think michael would be
averaging 45 points
without a problem he'd be at the line 20
times i mean
it it it's and it's all been that's what
they wanted right they geared this
to get offensive they don't they don't
it's like the nfl right with the with
the cornerbacks you can't touch a guy
they want offense and they're not giving
defenses a chance
so it's just and the three-point line
has really
changed really changed the game it
really has they finally figured it out
wise that shooting the three 50 times a
game
is better than you know laying the ball
in
three on two remember three on one
breaks you hey guys run to the wing
and then run right to the rim and get
away corner three
every time yeah i know
we sound like the old guy get off my
lawn i i
there was too much physicality back in
the 90s
yes and and it took away from greatness
there
there's too much freedom now where you
can't touch anybody and
uh you know i don't know if if you were
gonna make a change
would you move the three-point shot back
would you widen the court would would
you do anything drastic to help the nba
uh well i i like widen the court maybe
uh maybe widen the lane
uh but i think if you move that
three-point line
back it would probably be worse because
people are still going to do it
and you know there's so many guys that
shoot the three that shouldn't be
shooting right i mean if you're
like russell westbrook like he's a
career 30 percent
maybe or 29 i think he's the worst of
all time
is he a great is he one of the all-time
great players
that's a tough one i mean to average a
triple double was that three out of the
last four years he's done that no
now but there's a reason that that
hasn't happened since oscar robertson in
the 60s right
the game is that much different right i
mean you're when you're taking
53s in a game how many rebounds go out
to the free-throw line where
point guards can pick them up back in
the day that's not what happened
fours and fives were guys that got
rebounds and that's it
yeah point guards didn't get reba i bet
you if you look john stockton would have
games where he had no rebounds
and 17 assists and so it's the game's
different but again
to be to get a triple-double you have to
be involved in a whole lot of plays
but magic's the greatest point guard of
all time right
uh yeah i would take him okay and then
john stockton
you would take stockton over westbrook
yeah yeah okay oh yeah but to play with
yeah
yeah 100 jason kidd would you take him
over westbrook
uh yeah i think i'd rather play with him
chris paul
oh chris paul okay well scottie brooks
was saying that he thinks
russell westbrook might be the second
greatest point guard of all time now i
know it's his guy but he's on his team i
know
what do you have to say hey uh russell
westbrook i mean
these numbers are felonious i
dan he's the best athlete at the point
guard position to ever play
100 all right i know your t-time's in 20
minutes i'm
sorry if i held you up there from teeing
off
no i i have a member guest at the club
that i can't play in because i'm working
oh you're working tomorrow my bad so i
can't i can't play yeah
you've got a tough one tough life uh
john thanks for joining us bud great to
talk to you
great to catch up with you there that's
john berry nba on espn radio
and i didn't even bring up the easter
story